[Música]
mientras ven a sus compañeros de trabajo
cargando su retrato su familia amigos y
los habitantes de la ciudad de gam bulle
siguen conmocionados
y no la volveremos a ver es triste es
injusto constituyó así todavía no sé si
estoy más triste o más enfadada
cómo estás mis pensamientos están con su
marido y sus dos hijas es un momento de
silencio dirigido por el primer ministro
francés quien concedió a stephanie mon
facme la más alta distinción civil del
país
un hombre apareció de la nada para
asesinarla salvajemente y con una
determinación escalofriante
poco malika por qué tanto odio hacia
ella su colega fue asesinada por servir
a su país
pasquet save the song pain la madre de
dos de 49 años trabajaba con la policía
como administrativa de la comisaría del
pueblo al suroeste de parís
sage libia sienta bien reunirse ver esta
foto suya y pensar en ella y poseer
agentes de todo el país se unieron para
presentar sus respetos es la
decimoséptima persona que trabaja en la
policía y muere en un atentado
terrorista desde 2014